Identification. This is Station thirteen with face band.
And Karen Craig and it's recorded on Thursday the fourth of September one thousand nine hundred seventy.
And this is the side. Tapes coming up in a few seconds for faith over to you.
When we all struggle a sion book was published.
There was a great need for that at that particular time because to publish the works of all authors.
Now many people who were left wing had difficulty getting published and this was a good way of overcoming it.
It was Frank how does it become a flourishing publishing.
Publishing some of us try to use most famous authors and regrettably.
After But it had a good go I would say for ten years. And how often I became very involved in it.
I became the treasurer at one stage and hundreds became the secretary. For new software. But when it was formed.
Well when there was a chance of raising the works of quite a number of people whom we would not have rated.
So many of the authors were saying to me why don't you write. There was William Hadfield And. Different of course and.
They were getting at me and I thought my God that would be the last thing I could do.
Although I came from a family who were great. All right. And we knew all about the pain and. I never saw so for us.
Well times past. And I had to go to London and.
I haven't been to London for quite some years because as I said previously I didn't have a passport and.
I reclaimed nine hundred sixty seven. When I thing went off to new mayor and had a couple of weeks.
So I had a passport and when the invitation came through. I said to write. I love you. I don't think I could live.
But I could stay there for a long time. Previously I was in for eleven months.
And it was lovely to go back to that magnificent city with and. And. And.
It offers me a lot of everything for me when I go to London Bloomsbury. Covent. And the paddock and.
The festival and it's just wonderful. So when the invitation came through. I said oh yes I'm coming.
I have never met before family. So when I. It was at the airport. I knew really it was. It was just like secondhand so.
Now I was. In a hotel in the Ivanhoe. I became. But I hadn't given a lecture to the. Tropical department.
That was very interested in what was happening in the center children. And the doctor. I think. To be a pediatrician.
She had already completed.
Become very good friends actually but she took care of me and came in the morning
and in the evening to the hotel because. What's actually. And I think she was somewhere.
She is now very very famous in Australia. Lives in practice. Who deals specifically with fear. And. And him.
Came another Australian who came and said pack your suitcase. You're coming to play. I packed up.
He put me and my suitcase in his little car and we went off to where he had a unit.
He is an Australian lawyer so I should say he's back in Sydney or has been there for a long time very different.
And I was leaving London. I'd already been to Geneva and from London. I was to go to Mexico. So I recovered it.
There also placed in front of the. Drinking.
And then he the next night he said well I don't have to know in a nice place. And then on top. You offered Heathrow.
And I said to you now ask me about my people and I told him. My father came from. And he said Isn't it beautiful.
I don't know I've never heard. My father and I. Well it's a great silent happened that he's from here.
And one of the places I stopped there and I thought about this to Mexico. I was doing a job in Mexico for.
The Australian Government. And. Taken care of by High Commission. Through customs and. Hotel arrangements for the job.
And the job was to make a report that knew him and it had been built by primarily. A project. Still very new.
And they took me through one full experience.
They're travelling from Mexico to Australia is very long because you probably know.
So I had plenty of time to think what I was going to do with my life and I thought everyone.
Carried this bloody around in my. And it's ready to jump out.
And now I'm going to do so when I arrived I have recently come for a few days and I'm from.
How would you like to go to Kamya And I said when he said we're off. So we both went off to Kenya and. The Priest.
Yes precedent was what was his. Who was jailed for so long with my arm doesn't matter. It will come out later.
And it's very interested in the struggle of the man for independence in Kenya.
And I couldn't help the British for what they were doing in the African states
and that there is corruption at the level of.
I can say thank you to the British for teaching This is where you get money and money is the most important thing.
So when I went in there. I want to know what was happening with. The people who were.
And who gained independence for came here when because he was tied up with the environment.
It was at a time when he was doing a university thing and it was very important for him to go so far away.
So far eight which meant that I would be left alone in Kenya in Nairobi.
I was given an introduction by a friend who lives here to the first secretary of the High Commission in Kenya.
Cambridge and it turned out that Cambridge had married a person who had done some work for can't see.
So I had a good beginning. I went down to the office.
And the high commissioner himself over the discussion between myself.
And he came out and he said Oh come on Mrs Farron. I'm so pleased to meet you. When can we have lunch. This was got.
So I said. I'm not getting away from writing but I feel it. Time a fitting time to break. So I said I'm here.
I would have lunch at the Intercontinental. And so this happened and it's beautiful. To see the president. Now.
I had made it. Incidentally a couple of fellow strugglers here in Australia. And they came out for a peace. Congress.
And interest. Anyhow.
The next day came and went off tonight and he said from the dining room you could have the power to come here
and we were into the wind. And the one hundred great. Sitting in the shade of the tree in the parks and I'm unemployed.
After lunch back to my hotel. And it was a fear. Along the street and put your handbag in front. If you know you know.
And he says are you. And he told me an Australian. Through It. The previous morning and she'd had her kidneys taken.
I was very disappointed at what was happening in Kenya. The first secretary said a few nights later.
I'll show you how people really live
and they are about five kilometers from the city about two hundred thousand people living in a compound without
and he said. Had the government come to power than the corruption. And I was very distant past. Anyhow. The phone rang.
When I got back to the hotel. And said look the wife of the minister for trade.
Is to visit Australia for a conference call. She's very very worried about.
Has heard about the white house trailer and policy.
And I said Well no but she's still worried and I wondered if you would take. With. Of course.
He said well I will tell her so for someone to pick you up. So the next morning. I was called and that.
The chauffeur had to show. Plus. The chauffeur with a big green. The driver and a security guard. To drive.
God to take me to house. In front two policemen motorcyclists and. To protect me.
But this was most of showing showing off you know. And here we go psycho police it's got to flee.
I suppose because independence and independence and she was the wife of the Minister for Trade and I arrived
and right around this White Castle. It's different cream and green and blue and black and red. When I walked.
Into the welcome and began to ring the waiters came out. And you know. Take. Oh absolutely.
So that night I had dinner with Kendra because I wanted he wanted. The House and he was one costume.
And he said that woman. Before independence which wasn't going to think they had an independent. That woman.
And one of the first things that happened she was from. This was a black nation.
That had gained its freedom from color. Had a look at it and.
When I felt I should tell you that I was said to left it out and I had the streets I wasn't afraid of him.
It was just beautiful. The hotel I was staying with Mind you it was full of. Relics of color.
And you know but one intruded. I'm not happy. This is happening and the very next to. Timely that they put to.
The commission the country of the people.
They detained a women's conference when I was there and there was sitting on a stage I.V.
In the blue Mercedes Blue Cross.
And there were a great great lineup of women who were working for the captain
and the Prime Minister's Department all the various departments
but there was also a great number of women who'd come from. One who stood up and before I could come.
To sell a bunch of bananas and bread for my husband. Well. The women from the villages were very vocal. That polygamy.
Maybe legal. Now you know many of the women from the villages have said my husband left me with four children.
He's gone with another woman other said you know he and his fourth wife in some cases they just have the children.
So we want this illegal.
When the motion was put woman employed by the captain was game enough to visit because I well I wouldn't be in a job
the next day. Because Kenya has had three wives and I went with ministers who had. Polygamy.
You know very serious problem for the women. Well.
Before we went from there over to Tanzania and Kenya Rogers had tied at half with. High.
Or ambassador in Africa which was to meet us at the airport at the airport after the plane and taken off
and leave our house.
One morning we've been friends with the first secretary and he had a wife who was involved in fact.
In the campaign for the referendum. Down in Tasmania. So the doors were open which was marvelous and.
Would you like to see where they lived and. So we hopped in the car and the.
White House and the like and we will greeted housekeeper who looked after her. Because then I think.
He was the one who married very. He was the one who married Rita Hayworth long before your time.
Caroline tell you about the actress and so the housekeeper got rather friendly with me.
Hair flowing blowing in the wind she don't mind if you other women also. Place. Anyhow. We can.
And I said let's go to what was it before it was before independence. Doesn't matter. Forgotten what. You here pretty.
Said your show. So I was talking with a friend who lives up to. This village and she said.
It will be interesting and a couple of days later she rang and asked if she could come with me and her daughter.
And this person had never been I don't think she'd ever been out of New South Wales.
So I said Oh yes of course it was such and such.
And then I had a ring from very different who was here last week for lunch for all our wedding anniversary.
And she said Would you take my daughter. And her daughter. I think it.
Economics and I said oh yes you know the sleeping bag will be pretty rough. So we all went off the four of us.
We arrived it was a package deal put into the ground. After two days. I've got to find how to get to.
This is the seventy's isn't it. What are we talking about that. Early seventy's.
Carol and look for the priest to have missions all over the place. And the other two.
Protestant missions around the place.
And I said well I'll go down to shop around the place to find a tiny little island didn't have a.
Strip you could only go by. And we're all come back here after lunch we found out. I've often seen you coming in. With..
The Federal Member for T.I.A. And sometimes. How things caring.
And I said all very well I'm just trying to find out if the might be a little trading off to them for he said he made a
phone call and he said get down to the bank. And there I think it was the manager and.
He's going to try to they're going to hammer him tomorrow. So. He was waiting for me.
He said How many of you and I said oh five. He said. All right well it'll cost you dollars. That is called the From.
And it will lead from such and such to eight o'clock tonight. OK I'll go back and tele other stuff and go off to use.
And she wasn't quite sure what she was going to take in the case of beautiful. Great looking face.
She had these lovely. Paints which she would have made.
So I go back and tell them what if you got letters going to the place because we go back and write.
And the Presbyterian says no we're not going near it because you're all just as bad. You're going to do this.
I think you'll say What an awful lot we are getting tonight. So you've got to pack and get a taxi. Right.
And we'll meet here. In the fall here and. Beautiful. Simple but. A big suitcase.
And they have to have a six and sleeping bag. So I looked over and she's a beautiful person with a great sense if you.
And her daughter looked at her. When the taxis are right for her to Texas. We're down to the boat and they.
Say twenty meters thirty meters little. Rust. Dripping water started and it was. And there were men.
And every inch of space appear to be taken and the man who owned it. And he says come on.
And there was a little space on a day that my bottom could be seen and gave no consideration to the others
and I just about it in the bag. Yeah.